it's really impressive um i noticed
there's a camera
under the tono logo there very subtle um
is that recording her movements to see
if she's doing it correct she's an
instructor so obviously she's doing it
perfectly but
if i was doing it or you were doing it
we might need some
help is it going to tell you your
shoulders too high or too low eventually
we've put we've put a lot of sensors in
the system so you've got camera and
microphone those aren't activated yet
but the system gets smarter over time
we've all heard of cars that didn't know
how to drive themselves you wake up one
morning and suddenly they know how to
drive themselves
we have sensors inside the system uh
that measure
measure um speed acceleration range of
motion
power output on the cables uh the intel
the handles that we have on the system
actually have six axis gyros and then we
measure movement in three dimensions
and so there's a wealth of data uh that
is helping the system get smarter and
smarter over time and give you better
feedback so it would know if i was
holding it wrong
and then eventually it could be telling
me to make an adjustment exactly
but that's not in the system yet that's
something you'll learn over time when
you get data we have some stuff
in the system already today and with
every additional software release we're
going to be enabling more and more of
that intelligence
and then eventually if i want to take a
class with liz instead of her just give
me a program i can take a live class
maybe down there
actually that's actually one of the
reasons we put the camera in there yeah
that seems to me
to be the huge win is if people could
actually do one-on-one training and pay
for it is that going to be possible
one-to-one training you think
absolutely really this is you know right
now there there are barely enough
personal trainers uh in the country uh
to serve the us
uh there's about enough uh personal
trainers to serve about a third of one
percent of the us population
and that's going to double over the
course of the next few years uh with
a platform like this we're able to do
two things we're able to give many many
more people
access to personal training and we're
also able to take trainers and extend
their reach
so you can serve a much larger
population